la phrase qui est le plus dit c'est
j'imagine que les gens nous regardent
imagine vraiment tu veux dire ça à ma
meuf j'imagine que les gens nous
regardent
la fenêtre casse pas la tête
faire mes rideau
c'est non pas là comme ça non pas là
comme ça c'est par rapport à l'endroit
c'est normal quand tu es à la photo
copieuse et tout l'open space non mais
c'est vrai et tu as la photocopieuse il
y a tout le punchpad forcément tu vas
dire non pas là comme ça il y a quand
même Gérard de la compta
en 7e tout simplement c'est oui
il faut bien que oui pour que ça se
passe si les deux disent non ça sera pas
oui oh oui oui oh oui bah c'est bon oui
oh oui bah oui un oui on comprend
est-ce que tu la sens bien
[Musique]
calme-toi en 6e position
[Rires]
c'est je t'aime ah c'est beau c'est beau
et arrête bouffon
en 5e position c'est j'aime ton odeur
c'est va plus vite
je crève hein
pas plus vite à 3 en 3 je suis à toi
en deux fais ce que tu veux de moi
et en un en un prends-moi
merci est-ce que vous des phrases
inavouable tout en restant ne dites pas
complètement si vous voulez dire un truc
voilà parce que j'ai des petites idées
sur Daniel comme vous avez une phrase
voilà je vais demander quoi souvent j'ai
arrêté je suis foutu
franchement c'est le lacet quoi oui oh
oui oh oui
[Applaudissements]
ça fait peur quand même
dans deux secondes faut que je te
rappelle il y a ma femme qui m'appelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est la meilleure je vous cache pas on
fait des secondes surtout pour Daniel
non mais je dis Géraldine Delphine et
Béatrice voilà vous oh ben moi ce serait
plutôt classique ça va bébé ou je t'aime
[Rires]
il y a une petite côte pour change de
braquage tu vois c'est tranquille je lui
demanderai pas
alors on va alors on va faire Béatrice
chez nous c'est international c'est en
plusieurs langues
italien moi c'est anglais français donc
en fait
ton calcium
[Rires]
c'est pas des où on sait pas des moments
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va te revenir
pourquoi tu me dis jamais que tu jouis
tu m'interdit de t'appeler au bureau
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
excitant quand on dit juste prends-moi
je suis à toi de ça moi je crois pas je
crois pas aux phrases les plus utilisées
pendant un acte parce que je pense qu'à
partir du moment on a des phrases un peu
type comme un algorithme ça veut dire
que c'est automatique c'est une routine
et du coup c'est nul et c'est un tue
l'amour mais il y a pas tu dis pas
bonsoir
a priori on s'est vu quand même avant ça
c'est sûr
moi je trouve que l'enchaînement par
exemple de phrases comme prends moi ou
des ou des choses comme ça avec des je
t'aime voilà faire un peu le mix ça
c'est beau ah oui ça les propres
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le thème quoi genre t'aime
dentier
donc c'était fais-moi coulisser
l'andouillette dans le cresson ou des
trucs comme ça quoi
ça va pas Daniel
c'est parce que je suis à côté de toi
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
arrêtez là
le weekend
là tu peux y aller
c'était que ton mec où il avait des
personnes
l'a jamais su non
il est parti
avec tous ces souvenirs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a une petite remorque
derrière pour le deuxième
boomer le matin c'est fou ah ouais et
jamais et sa femme il me semble du coup
tu crois que ouais
c'était deux personnes
[Rires]